now to a hereditary condition that
threatens many lives in africa people
with sickle cell disorder produce red
blood cells that are unusually shaped
like crescents or sickles as the name
suggests now these can block blood
vessels and cause chronic pain and often
death the condition is particularly
common among people with african or
caribbean background
now 300 000 children are born with
sickle cell disease each year with
around three quarters of those in africa
nigeria is the worst affected country
but there are attempts to sound the
alarm as dw correspondent olisa chukumar
reports
drawing blood to prevent immense
suffering nigeria's sickle cell
foundation a non-profit organization is
trying to test as many blood samples as
possible so people can know their sickle
cell status mudukwe ukola or lokwade
kopola is at the forefront of these
efforts
she's lived with sickle cell disorder
for more than 60 years
it was very excruciating
i was always in and out
of the hospital
for one thing or another
infection i have to be transfused
my primary school days my secondary
school days
were not very good it wasn't a good
experience
she calls herself a sickle cell warrior
braving every day with strong support
from her family and with medical care
but for a disease with no easy cure
she wants to raise awareness to prevent
the need for the lifelong challenges it
brings
it is indeed very important at least
for people to know
because if despite all the awareness a
lot of people still don't know
so this community program is very much
important and this foundation has been
doing a lot
about this over 40 million nigerians are
healthy carriers of the sickle cell gene
but some are not even aware of it the
disorder can only occur when two of such
people have children
one in four of their offspring will have
sickle cell anemia
which causes chronic pain and often
death
many don't make it beyond their fifth
birthday this particular event today now
gives us opportunity to do their blood
tests
so they know again
before they start dating and getting
married
what their genotype is because that's
what determines if you are going to be
if you are going to pass the gene of the
disease to your offspring this is
exactly what more and more couples are
starting to do it's often even a
decisive factor for getting together as
we hear at a wedding registrar next door
knowing
about sick self if i met my wife it's an
eye opener before i get married so that
i will know what i'm going into into and
how to avoid them
enlightenment is going to play a lot of
growth
in eradicating sickle cell so that you
don't have to reach children into the
world
to suffer
that suffering is worsened by the huge
financial costs and the challenges
accessing quality healthcare nigeria
pose that's why the campaigners are
advocating
know your status the cheaper and safer
message of prevention
we can now speak to dalali atigbe atipo
she is the chief operating officer of 54
gene which is a pharmaceutical research
company pioneering the specialization in
african genetic material delay it's good
to have you on the program now less than
three percent of genomic data
represented in researches from african
populations so how much has this tiny
amount hampered the search for a cure
for sickle cell disorder
well thank you it's greatly hampered the
search for a cure and when we think
about it what's really contributed to
that is the fact that we don't have much
representation
when it comes to driving the science we
need more african scientists to help
bridge the disparity gap when you think
about driving genomics data research so
that we have greater participation from
african science those who look like
those who are affected by the disease
contributing in addition we need to be
able to have greater investment when we
talk about diagnostics and data for
being able to identify
the causes as well as those who need the
treatment related to sickle cell disease
is that lack of diagnostic capabilities
on the continent that also causes
delayed in disease identification as
well as crucial management of sickle
cell and the third area that is really
important is participation when we have
more patients participating who are of
african descent
that allows 54 companies like 54 gene as
well as the pharmaceutical industry to
understand and get better insights into
the disease and therefore power
innovative drug discovery
now there are other diseases whose cures
are yet to be found so where does sickle
cell rank in terms of priority in the
world's major research labs
and you brought up a very good point in
terms of the world's research labs i
mean most of the time we focus on
infectious diseases like covid19 because
obviously there's been a huge impact
globally when we think about disease
burden in africa and where typically
research has been directed to
things like hiv tb malaria usually come
up but there has to be much greater
focus when it relates to
non-communicable diseases which is where
sickle cell falls because actually
globally that is the biggest
representation of disease burden and
it's not infectious disease every single
day people are dealing with chronic
conditions that are that are affecting
both their daily lives as well as
mortality rates across worldwide and so
when you globally think about sickle
cell disease for which about 300 000 are
born with sickle cell disease every year
nigeria alone in particular
contributes to about 50 of that about
150 000 newborns are born with sickle
cell disease annually which represents
50 so how do we start addressing and
need to
put attention towards that particular
disease burden is the fact that we have
such a great cause and a need to focus
and not just look at infectious disease
like covert 19 alone
and at this rate so how close do you
think we are to finding a cure a ready
cure for sickle cell disorder
so i think that when you think about new
technologies for instance like gene
therapy
which is really a cure in itself when
you think about how to come about
treating sickle cell disease there's
hope but we need to actually really do
more and be able to come up with
innovative ways and mechanisms for which
we can address sickle cell in a manner
that supports the infrastructure that we
have within africa building up
capabilities continuing to build up
sustainable ways for which the
healthcare ecosystem can support new
technologies coming in
that will
really be able to democracize
availability as well as accessibility
for these innovative therapies and
that's what's going to be important for
driving um and and being able to address
and provide cures for sickle cell
all right delilah from 54 gene thanks
for speaking to us
thank you